okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p this
voicemail is a textbook example of
strawman okay take a listen to what this
caller says in response to my recent
story about coronavirus take a listen
why the day here calling for fort
lauderdale florida watching your show
the David Pakman show
right you left out a lot of information
a lot of it is not pragmatic or
realistic at all okay twenty thousand
people are not dying every day the
reports that you're looking at are
invested in by people who have a vested
interest of giving you false information
so remember what the caller says it's
twenty thousand people are not dying
every day let's continue you're using
that false information incorrectly it's
just saying I live down here
I go back and forth to the beach every
day right we're having a great time
they're enjoying their life there's no
sirens on a daily basis letting us know
that people are dying at a massive
aggressive rate okay you want to talk
with me and contact me I can give you
facts and proof in video feed to show
you what's actually going on regardless
of somebody who had some money and
fingers placed into an investment of
marketing the wrong idea but you seem to
support right so they say David you're
wrong twenty thousand people aren't
dying yeah I never said twenty thousand
people are dying I said 20,000 or 25,000
cases are being found each day in the
United States and that's true so this is
what's called the straw man arguing
against an argument I never made David
you're wrong that twenty thousand people
are dying never said twenty thousand
people are dying says there's no sirens
in Florida letting us know people are
dying I never said there were sirens in
Florida letting us know people were
dying what I'm saying is we have data
available if anything the data is
understating the severity of the problem
so guys do not make straw man arguments
it looks bad it's not good argue against
what I say rather than what you claim
that I said we've got a great bonus show
for you today become a member to get
instant access at join pakman.com we
will talk about an incredible story from
a hair salon about masks and coronavirus
and so so much more I will see you on
the bone
so if you are a member if not I'll see
you tomorrow